I've seen you thinking more than one  movie play piano and unless you were  faking it you're quite good no I  actually play yeah I'd love to hear you  play sometime oh well you know it's  crazy I just happen to have this right  here yes fantastic that's convenient  that is a very handy keyboard yeah what  do you what are you gonna play for us  well um you might recognize the melody  but I put some words to it in honor of  Hot Tub Time Machine 2 coming out so  here we go working on the movie and it's  always right we all are crazy  [Applause]  Time Machine 2 it comes out  dude  Time Machine to get your hot dog in your  bunker sniff some blue  [Applause]  go  [Music]  back on this guy you know I want an  electric guitar that doesn't plug in  you